[Applause]
[Applause]
sorry i can't help you both in
simultaneously but that's the way it
goes
now ladies if you're closing as close to
me as you can we'd like to find out what
your names are and where you are from
we'll start with you please i am miss
dealer harris from knoxville tennessee
miss delia harris of knoxville tennessee
and your name please
this is miss bertie harris of knoxville
tennessee now uh
this secret of theirs i want to tell you
sounds on the surface of it almost
impossible i assure you it has been
documented and we'll explain it later on
so miss birdie and miss delia harris if
you'll whisper your secret to me we'll
show it at the same time the folks at
home here we go
uh panel to help uh classify the harass
sisters secret the clue concerns a
relative of theirs and henry we'll start
with you i think please
uh miss uh delia harris is this relative
of yours a famous uh man
uh i think our opinion would be that he
individually was not famous now
well
was he part of a famous family
no that's not quite it he always say
famous we mean somebody whose name we we
can say and you would immediately
recognize the answer there again is no
you related to nobody
were you related to some well i mean
as part of a secret it must be somebody
we recognize one way or another
no not necessarily
well you said in the beginning it's
almost unbelievable yes it is
and it it concerns a relative yes
what is it a woman
no
well it is a man yeah well does a man
have a title like he was the first to do
something or um no
all right with twenty dollars down a
little knowledge gained uh and i don't
blame you it's tough we go to carol
burnett please
he was the last to do something
[Music]
uh was he your brother
no your father no your husband no
you were both married to the same man
[Music]
my name is
i've gotten to know these two ladies you
don't get much past them
forty dollars down forty dollars to go
will go please to bill cullen father
brother husband have been mentioned
uncle possibly
no blood relative yes cousin no
grandfather yes
you both have the same grandmaster
how about that both of these sisters
have the same grandfather is that right
right no
remember friends you heard it here first
it was it was a rhetorical question uh
your grandfather did something did he
in which we're interested
yes now this is where we get back to
your original area it is not the
gentleman himself whose name remains
famous it was the event with which he
was connected was it
civil war event civil war eventually
sixty dollars down twenty dollars to go
would you say a bill civil war event no
no all right do we go to betsy pop
please
well miss birdie and miss devia uh is it
something that has to do with um
uh
with the state of tennessee
no
does it have something to do with
washington d.c as far as our government
is concerned
oh you scared me then does it have
something to do with the state of
washington
no
washington himself
no no indirectly and really
says no what are you saying with birdie
indirectly indirectly indirectly
all right we've lost the 80 dollars
henry thinks he knows what it is this is
a very remote possibility and i'm gonna
do this wrong because i got the years
wrong was your grandfather
the
grandson of washington
no
i told you that this secret sounded
impossible and you may need a pencil and
paper to follow it but i doubt it the
secret that miss birdie and miss delia
harris share is that their grandfather
now understand this their grandfather
was a soldier in the revolutionary war
the revolutionary war of course being
from 1776 to 1781 mr when was your
grandfather simon harris born he was
born in 1766.
well now that would have made him 10
years old when he uh when the
revolutionary war began uh he didn't get
in at the age of 10 how old was he when
he got in 12th he entered as a cipher
uh-huh he ended not as a soldier but as
a piper but subsequently he did see
action didn't he yes he was at valley
forge
with washington's army and then he was
at corn wallace surrender at yorktown
in fact his name is on the monument at
yorktown now this is just unbelievable
to think my grandfather be able to say
my grandfather was in the revolutionary
war now here's where you might need a
pencil and paper to follow this uh how
find out how only two generations
separate these ladies from the american
revolution simon harris their
grandfather was married in 1796 and he
had 10 children his youngest child and
the father of these two ladies was born
in 1818
so by the way if it isn't amazing enough
that their grandfather fought in the
revolutionary war let me tell you also
that their father was too old to fight
in the civil war
now their father was married twice he
had ten children by his first marriage
uh
and three children by his second
marriage when he was in his seventies
and of those three children these two
ladies are of those three and also
another sister mary lou who is watching
the show at home ms dillia that's a
pretty large and complicated family
isn't it rather
the matter of fact it's kind of
interesting to know that miss bertie and
miss delia have nieces and nephews who
are older than they are
isn't that pumas burning very true
well mr william is brady harris i want
to thank you so much for sharing your
secret with us tonight your money and
your bristol myers gift package will be
waiting for you backstage it's been a
rare privilege
[Applause]
you